olá pessoal de quem faltou eu agora me
sempre a sobrancelha cantor falou adam o
estrago de quebo guiné está uma série
que vocês vão gostar por isso vou
continuar né nós vamos chegar à noite
cinco contínuo é que o google jogo
domingo joga aí tá muito vento aqui e aí
eu aprovei que lançam jogo e por pouco
não é muito barulho muito confuso assim
ai meu deus a xuxa pegou
não estou aí vocês viram o cara de homem
o tofu bizarro ainda agora entre os
abril o geddel a abrir 21 santana é um
parceiro assim não sei se a filha nesta
noite gasta mais rápido senão não dá meu
nunca vai aí não seria isso não tem
muito medo muito medo muito medo muito
mourinho mesma cueca a janela número
janela sapo ajuda mas a
11 eu não o conheço há muito tempo era
este está muito bom muito bom parece pão
com manteiga bateu na pureza janela
tranquilo armário portais de lançar um
site estudo mané não deu não deu não deu
não deu
eu vou conseguir agora consegui lo saiba
que já há quase uma brecha nela já o 101
e sai não entra já diz aoki um fórum
conjunto claro que indica era lotado no
armário pois é isso que michael não
conseguiu abrir nada até agora o que é
muito bom vende lançam não vai entrar
aqui por agora o único inscrito este
jogo é ser rápido o caraças josé dumont
cheirar o sovaco através saime isso o
gasto uma união muito grande diz coisas
tentação da união vai entrar não vai
junto tem jeito não vai querer ai ai
dentro
em média o cachorro é muito independente
e não vai falhar a sul da ilha de novo
sai por dentro aí eu vou ficar aqui
agora
não não estava toda eu estava dentro de
um armário como é que é possível basta
carga explica em comunicado que está
sendo muito bacana é que a taxa da união
na janela obviamente que o brilho para
sua demanda espreitar só que não é um
funk em jarro que está pensando que não
importa saia e quase consegui comentar o
vídeo já é muita emoção na minha alma o
que plantaram 2 mil empregos por falar à
luz gasto pireu não vai para dentro não
se passa nada está tudo tranquilo eu
preciso ir apanhar pelo sentimento sai
daqui e me choquei vai lá baixo rápido o
que eu posso dizer é o seguinte eu posso
nunca apanhar pilhas parte da cana
porque eu vou estar sempre mais da
caneta do melhor que eu tenho que fazer
é mesmo não gostaria pneu apontar banho
flash lite e não basta quase nada aí
está a superar outra vez ai ai
na janela que ela demonstra jogo tudo
escuro aqui porque agora eu não consegui
ver nada eu não conheço quem quer
assaltava costa tudo janela a ser o
pessoal foi muito intenso tá muito funk
intenção duas 56 da manhã na holanda
na holanda o macaco não distrair macaco
tac na janela o fim da manhã o que tem
34 e ainda está no armário tenor mário
vai poder falar sério e outro
completamente arrepiado no período cuja
tae-jae tossindo cujas águas tem muita
pilha vai podemos temos quatro eu gosto
quando o quarto fica assim mais ou menos
iluminado nem porque sempre na primeira
alguma coisa agora eu contato escura
isso embora muita cueca saia perdendo
vai poder em 2000 teria 61 4 40 m é
pessoal acho que às vezes consegue sair
perdendo de 1 a 0 que expulsou porque
temos quatro pessoas 15 e 21 15 e 20 vai
falar foi o próprio filho daniel a 0
unido já não me enganei e na unha
olha só teria inspira eu já só tem um
pneu alaor avança nessa ae
saí para que sim que se sujeitem 30 só
sei que foquem 30 da manhã
eu vou conseguir ai ai ai que costumam
atingir ou sai por dentro do armário que
é isso que 40 e na rápida ai meu deus ai
uma etapa bem dura agora fica é isso só
vamos ficar por aqui com espírito vai
fazer senão estável a sério esta noite
cinco burro muito mas é isso que passo
aqui favorito e até a noite só eu